it's a crazy story I think I
yeah I think I was probably I don't no I
was in uh I'd have to say probably
fourth or fifth grade
fourth or fifth grade sixth grade maybe
around sixth grade something like that
and I'm skateboarding in front of The
Comedy Store
with in my little league outfit and some
kids pull up in a gremlin
they pull up in a gremlin which is a car
yeah which is a car not something not
not like a gizmo like I played in the
movie no like a gremlin not like a furry
monster no not like a flurry monster
kids don't know a gremlin now okay well
thank you for explaining to your
audience a lot of kids also don't know
the Gremlins furry monster yeah bro what
the you doing trying to throw them
in your daughter under the bus that's
not cool I'm just trying to cater down
so turn to the right click that yeah so
this pulled up and I'm this is this
happened so they pull up in front of the
comedy store and I got my free my my
skateboard that I got from Lonnie Toft
who was sponsored by Sims and I used to
get free skateboards and they pulled up
this is a custom board he made for me
and they asked me they go yo little dude
where's the 405 freeway and I just go
it's over there you go about 20 miles or
15 miles down there and they're like
awesome and I turn around and the one
kid
um jumps out of the gremlin and he
steals my skateboard my custom
skateboard right from under your feet
right from under my feet and then takes
off but I remembered the license plate
and I still remember to this day it's
k-u-r-t-z-q so k z u r t z q k u r t z q
I say this to myself I remember I go
upstairs with my mom and she's in the
office doing the lineup making sure how
he's not on the list and um get him off
the list he's not ready he's good go to
carpet he's trying to sell carpet yeah
you're gonna send them home back to
Canada Polly want to leave but I
saved his ass
so uh so I threw up in my little league
hat I remember the thing we called the
police wait we threw up in your hat yeah
because I was crying because they stole
my skateboard oh okay yeah I threw up on
my little cat Okay and um you couldn't
make it to a toilet no I was crying I
was heaving it was my my skateboard that
they made for me it was like a special
thing so then
um so we reported to the police and then
one day about a couple weeks later I'm
sitting I'm sitting uh uh at school
eating my sandwich and the principal
comes up to me Taps on my shoulder and
says come to my office and I'm like oh
I'm in trouble I'd walk in the
office and there's my skateboard
but it's the story is not ending okay
so there's a punch line here so that so
they found my skateboard so then about a
week later I'm skateboarding in front of
my house with my friend David Thompson
and he says can I bomb your skateboard I
want to do a kick turn I'm like dude
you're gonna it up you know goes no
no I want the up so he doesn't kick
Journey Falls the skateboard goes in the
Street and it gets run over and
smashed in two by a gremlin buy a
gremlin it up yeah so that was
Miss skateboard story sorry
don't apologize it's a great story
foreign
[Music]